this morning a Russian judge denied bail
for an American being held on spying
charges the court session was Paul
Wieland's first public appearance since
he was arrested more than three weeks
ago Elizabeth Palmer was in Moscow where
Wieland's Russian lawyer talked about
the case and his clients response good
morning I'm standing in front of the
Moscow City Court which is where
Wieland's hearing was held although most
of it took place in secret in fact even
the representative from the US Embassy
wasn't allowed in we got our first
glimpse of Whelan when everybody
including the cameras was invited to
hear the judge's decision
Paul Whelan as as usual in Russian
courts stood behind glass in a sort of
prisoner's cage he looked relaxed even
though his Russian wasn't good enough to
understand what was going on and he had
to be briefed later by his lawyer and
his translator earlier the lawyer
vladimir nabokov had told me that when
Whelan was arrested he was in possession
of state secrets on a memory stick a
Russian website with close links to
Russia's security services is now saying
that those state secrets were in fact a
list of employees inside Russia's
Ministry of Defence with links to spying
women's lawyer told me essentially that
he's going to plead ignorance that Paul
Whelan had no idea that material was in
any way classified the lawyer also told
me that so far he's only seen a fraction
of the state's evidence he is going to
go ahead and appeal the no bail decision
but if that fails he said Paul Whelan is
looking at at least six more months in a
Russian jail for CBS this morning I'm
Elizabeth Palmer in Moscow